[Musique]
il est d'un peu plus de 21h quand jean
michel fourgous le candidat l'est
républicain vient annoncer sa défaite
dans la 11e circonscription des yvelines
sa seule satisfaction être en tête dans
sa ville d'elancourt
c'est vrai que j'ai toujours une petite
déception mais je dirais qu'il ya une
stèle tsunami et nationales que écouter
chez démarche est content de voir que ma
ville n'a pas pris l'eau entre
guillemets elle a été touchée par ce
n'est ni bon c'est là où je travaille le
plus quand même les résultats sont
partiels mais il sait déjà qu'il ne
remportera pas ce siège de député que
lui a ravie benoît hamon il ya cinq ans
jean michel fourgous adresse alors un
salut républicain à la gagnante qu'il va
croiser plus tôt que prévu nadia est
rejoint en effet la mairie d'elancourt
après s'être saluer et avoir transmis
quelques conseils
c'est l'occasion aussi pour les deux
adversaires de quelques mises au point
après des échanges tendus pendant la
campagne le déclaratif c'est bien le
mieux c'est
donc ils vont bien que les gens
attendent d'un soldat rapide
si je lui
oui nous avons un défi une gagnante
nouvelle en politique qui après une
campagne de terrain a relayé le message
du président de la république voit ses
efforts récompensés
elle est élue avec 52,96 % des voix
contre 47 0 4%
pour jean michel fourgous un 2e tour
marqué par un record d'abstention 58 3%
en forte augmentation par rapport au
premier tour
je suis effectivement extrêmement
satisfaite des du résultat après après
ces longues semaines de travail ces
longues semaines ou tous suis allé à la
rencontre de nous de nos concitoyens et
c'est aussi une grande fierté
aujourd'hui pour moi d'en arriver là
effectivement il ya quelques mois
j'étais cadre dans une banque
aujourd'hui je suis député à l'assemblée
nationale auprès du président emmanuel
macron donc pour moi c'est d'autant plus
une immense fierté de porter un projet
un projet comme celui là qui est de
celui de celui de la république en
marche à seulement 30 77 femmes actives
cadre à paris est originaire de trappes
devient la 11e députés en marche des
yvelines ces priorités d'élus la
moralisation de la vie politique et la
réforme du code de travail qu emmanuel
macron compte mettre en oeuvre dès cet
été
elle va mettre en place une permanence
dans sa circonscription et a lancé une
plateforme collaborative pour donner la
parole aux habitants de la 11e
circonscription
[Applaudissements]
après une soirée où elle retrouve sa
famille ses amis ses soutiens et les
marcheurs elle salue tous ceux qui l'ont
accompagné durant cette campagne
vous avez pris de votre temps
sonnette de vote en professionnel à
temps familial parfois effectivement ça
va piquer je fais mais vous l'avez fait
et je vous remercierai jamais assez pour
ce que pour éviter les oui nous l'avons
fait nous avons battu venoix avant nous
avons 26 ans michel fourgon elle sait
qu'elle date de voir s'installer vite
pour travailler dans ces bureaux de
l'assemblée
elle y partira d'ailleurs pour une
visite dès demain matin avant une
session de formation pour les nouveaux
arrivants et la journée d'ouverture de
la prochaine législature avec l'ensemble
des députés prévu le 27 juin
[Musique]